Speaker 1: This is a very strange headline.
Donald Trump has filed a lawsuit against his
own niece as well as The New York Times. Now, let
me translate. I'm going to tell you the story,
but let me translate it for you. Reporters
investigated things that were newsworthy.
And Donald Trump really doesn't like it and
he's suing. OK, here's the article from CNBC.
Former President Donald Trump filed a one hundred
million dollar lawsuit Tuesday against his niece,
Mary Trump, and The New York Times claiming
they conspired to obtain his tax returns for the
paper's Pulitzer Prize winning story, Pulitzer
winning story on his undisclosed finances. The
lawsuit asserts that married Trump and three New
York Times reporter Suzanne Craig, David Barstow
and Russell Bednar were engaged in what the suit
calls an insidious plot and an extensive crusade
to obtain Trump's taxes. Now, notice none of
these so far, none of that signals a crime, right?
What they mean is there was a newsworthy story
around Trump's taxes and Trump hiding his taxes.
And there was an awareness of that among
investigative reporters who tried to obtain
them now, then it gets to allegations that,
at least in theory, could could be criminal.
The defendants engaged in an insidious plot to
obtain confidential and highly sensitive records,
which they exploited for their own benefit and
utilized as a means of falsely legitimizing their
publicized works. It's still very weak, like what
are the damages and what is the wrongdoing here?
Craig Barstow and Wepner received the Pulitzer
Prize in 2019 for explanatory reporting for their
series of stories, which provided the public with
an unprecedented look at the former president's
finances. Mary Trump has said she released
Trump's tax returns to The New York Times
in her best selling 20/20 book about her uncle.
Too Much and Never Enough How My Family Created
the World's Most Dangerous Man. And in media
interviews, which the lawsuit notes in the book,
The Daughter of Trump's brother, Fred Jr.
paints an authoritative portrait of Donald J.
Trump and the toxic family that made him reacting
to this. In a statement, Mary Trump called her
uncle desperate, quote, I think he's a loser and
he is going to throw anything against the wall
he can. It's desperation. The walls are closing
in and he is throwing anything against the wall
that he thinks will stick. As is always the case
with Donald, he'll try and change the subject.
The New York Times said in a statement it
plans to challenge the lawsuit statement
from a spokesperson for the paper. Danielle
Rhodes says, quote, The Times coverage of
Donald Trump's taxes helped inform citizens
through meticulous reporting on a subject
of overriding public interest. This lawsuit is an
attempt to silence independent news organizations,
and we plan to vigorously defend against that
lawsuit filed in New York State Court. It alleges
that the reporter relentlessly sought out his
niece and convinced her to smuggle the records out
of her attorney's office and turn them over to the
times. So what is what is this really about? This
is about Trump's furious reporters investigated
and reported on something that was newsworthy.
And Trump wants to punish them. Now, of course,
at any time, Donald Trump could publish his taxes
and prove the story wrong. If the conclusions
of these stories about his taxes are out of
context or they're not complete. Right. If
Trump believes what was released of my taxes
is incomplete and it paints an incorrect picture,
release the full taxes and then we'll actually get
the full picture. He could do that at any time to
prove the story wrong. But this is all distract,
distract, distract. And I don't think it's also
crazy to consider whether the real news of the
last five days is, number one, that when Trump
and his team were pushing the big lie about
the 2020 election, they knew that it was a lie,
that we've learned more so over the last week.
The document with the six point plan outlining how
Donald Trump wanted to use Mike Pence to steal the
election that came to light over the last five
days. And so to some degree, this entire lawsuit
may just be an attempt to distract from that. But
I believe it will go absolutely nowhere. Nowhere
I would be I'm not a betting man, but I would be
willing to bet that this goes absolutely nowhere.
And maybe someday we will get Trump's taxes,
although at this point, do do we do we even still
care? I know there are some in my audience who do,
others who say who even cares at this point. But
remember, he may be back in twenty, twenty four.
And so all else being equal. I do think it would
be a great thing to finally get a hold of those
taxes. Let me know your thoughts. If you disagree,
you can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We have a fantastic program for you today and
it continues right after this short break.
Remember that our program is mostly funded
by viewers and listeners who get memberships at
Join Pakman Dotcom, we do an extra show every
day weekdays, guys. Come on, not seven days a
week. That'd be crazy. Weekdays we do an extra
show for our members called the Bonus Show. It
is award winning, although we create and give
the awards so it may not be worth that much.
We also offer commercial free audio and video
streams of the show every day to our members.
You can sign up at join Pakman Dotcom